originaire du royaume uni stéphanie
rambo est la première femme à la tête du
trianon palace un hôtel cinq étoiles
créée en 1910 emblématique et de la
ville de versailles une fierté pour la
nouvelle directrice générale cette scène
hôtel personnellement pour laquelle je
suis très attaché ça fait quelques
années que je travaille avec un jeune et
j'ai vu un petit peu cet hôtel dans le
contexte mon travail d'avants et c'était
toujours l'hôtel qui m'a passionné donc
évidemment très fier sa passion pour
l'hôtellerie elle la tient de son oncle
propriétaire de deux hôtels dans le nord
de l'angleterre elle y a débuté le
métier j'ai commencé mon travail dans
l'hôtellerie en angleterre dans des
forums fonctions
plus tôt dans la partie opérationnelle
j'ai rencontré longuement mari qui est
français après on arrive en france
c'était plutôt dans la partie
commerciale marketing pour laquelle j'ai
passé des années les rênes de
l'établissement versailles et lui ont
été confiées au mois de janvier 2022 ait
des responsabilités qui demande beaucoup
d'implication
c'est beaucoup de sens de détail et
quelque part c'est aussi investir
beaucoup plus à l'âge est beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus longue donc c'est vraiment
de se mettre dans les chaussures de nos
clients par rapport à ses attentes ses
besoins c'était finir en bout a déjà son
endroit préféré la suite terrasse pour
sa vue imprenable sur la ville et le
château de versailles donc là vous avez
devant vous une vue magnifique du
château de versailles évidemment vous
avez la ville a goûté sur votre côté
gauche et là vous avez toute la terre
vue du château de versailles à la toute
la verdure devant vous également à long
terme la directrice générale souhaite
accroître le prestige de l'hôtel pour
l'heure elle prépare la haute saison le
waldorf astoria versailles trianon
palace est actuellement en train de
recruter et former les équipes pour
cette importante période à venir